okay so 1899 is now out and the new
Netflix series has a lot to unpack from
its ending throughout this video I want
to break down the series all the hidden
details in it and also go over what
happens in its final few scenes what I
love about the series is that it starts
to fall into your thinking that you've
figured out the ending of it but then
the last couple of minutes just
completely pull the rug out from under
you you're probably thinking what the
hell is going on and in this video I aim
to explain the ending whilst also giving
my theories for what could happen next
time in the end it's revealed that Mora
is in fact in the year 2099 and on a
spaceship known as the Prometheus no not
that one forget about that one however
the final scene actually shares some
similarities to the Voyages that are
often depicted in Sci-Fi movies in order
to make the long Journeys passengers are
often put to sleep in stasis and this
show makes it appear that the
simulations are fed to them in order to
keep their minds occupied these
characters all seemingly are down for
the long nap and Maura awakens from this
to find herself on board a ship which is
overseen by a the Kirin now before we
get into the ending I feel like we had
to talk about the major events that lead
up to it the first section of this video
will be going over the influences in the
show the triangles that appear
throughout and also the details that
lead towards the end in this series We
join the passengers of the Kerberos as
they head out on a voyage all the way to
New York the ending twist is that
they're probably doing the same thing
but rather than heading out to Americare
they're heading out to a new planet
either way they all have their own
reasons for starting a new life with
most of the characters either running
from something or receiving letters from
loved ones that beckon them out there
this is most notably seen from Mora
who's carrying a letter from her
apparently missing brother however he is
in fact probably calling her out to her
new home now sticking with the initial
simulation on the boat we watch as they
come across the kerberos's sister ship
the Prometheus which is almost
completely abandoned this was the ship
that Maura's brother was on when he
apparently vanished and we see how the
other passengers have a connection to it
now the show draws a lot of inspiration
from your life and this is very much a
vessel that's in the same vein of the
Mary Celeste that ship was found
abandoned in 1872 with no sign of what
happened to the crew or where they left
it to this day it stands as one of the
biggest Unsolved Mysteries and we still
don't really have a concrete answer as
to what happened to the passengers ideas
have mysteriously abandoned vessels are
something that we have laced throughout
horror and in the film Event Horizon we
watch as that too is discovered with its
crew completely missing similar to those
aboard the Kerberos the characters in
the film start to have strange visions
and adds an extra dimension of horror to
all of the proceedings lastly when
watching this show I also couldn't help
think of the 2009 film triangle I don't
want to spell what happens in it but
involves people out at Sea discovering
an abandoned ship and then getting stuck
in a Time loop I definitely recommend
that you check it out as it's one of the
most well thought out time travel movies
I I think I've ever seen a triangles are
also laced throughout the show I think
we'd be remissed for not talking about
the Bermuda Triangle all and how this
too influenced the series in case you
don't know the area known as The Devil's
Triangle is Infamous for the amount of
aircraft and ships that have disappeared
whilst navigating it there's been a
number of Supernatural explanations for
this ranging from giant squids to aliens
to people not liking the video and being
cursed because of it all of these
aspects came to mind when watching 1899
as those on the Kerberos try to get to
the bottom of what was going on now in
case you don't know Kerberos is actually
a technical term that also has links to
Greek mythology the word actually
originates from Cerberus and if you know
you myths and legends then you'll be
aware that this character God at the
underworld this idea of a figure being
the thing that's put in place Between
Two Worlds is also how it's adapted in
the modern day when it comes to
computers Kerberos is basically a
security protocol and this authenticates
a requests between an untrusted Network
and a trusted one for example the signal
between your computer and the internet
has to pass through a Kerberos first
show of course all also has doorway
slays throughout it then being locked
and unlocked at several points we have
the one connected to the ship that
connects to the other side the doorways
that the little Beetle unlocks the
Gateway between the first and second
class and so on and so forth when the
boy is cast overboard he of course also
comes back through a doorway in a
cabinet which is mirrored by the doorway
in the cabinet on the Prometheus in the
scene that we first meet him there's
very much this idea that everything has
an opposite and other side to it which
is embedded in the show's DNA the series
opens with Maura talking about the human
brain which is itself divided into two
sections and have visions of an asylum
hint that something else is going on
here the theme for the series is also a
cover of White Rabbit by Jefferson
Airplane this is based on Alice in
Wonderland and that of course was also
about tumbling down the rabbit hole in
order to discover a new world and an
altered perception the Prometheus also
has a double meaning to it too with this
being named after the Titan who stole
fire from the gods he gave it to The
Mortals and typically the usage of the
name is meant to Mark Humanity gaining a
newfound knowledge this is definitely
seen in the ship which brings with it
someone who drastically Alters the
perspective of those on board we very
much get the idea though that someone
else is working behind the scenes to
control the events on the ship and
there's this constant feeling that this
is all played out before now this video
is sponsored by established titles a fun
and novel way to preserve the natural
Woodlands of Scotland while helping
Global reforestation efforts establish
titles lets you call yourself a lady
Lord or a LED due to a traditional
Scottish custom you see landowners used
to refer to themselves as this and
established titles allows you to buy at
least one square foot of dedicated land
and a private estate in edleston
Scotland on top of this it's a great way
to help out the environment as
established titles or planetary with
every single order they work with global
Charities like one tree planet and trees
for the future to help with
reforestation efforts so if you pick up
a plot you can refer to yourself as a
lord whilst also helping to preserve the
picture address Woodlands of Scotland
and there also comes with a bit of an
ego boost on top of all this
environmental stuff you can officially
change your name on credit cards plane
tickets your dating profile whatever you
want they also give you certificate
confirming your Lord's ship and a unique
plot Number that confirms your exact
plot of land but before Kevin's spoilers
you punk I am the Lord of this realm now
in addition to this established titles
have also told me that the first 200
people who use my link in the
description below will be given a plot
within walking distance of mine it makes
an amazing last minute gift and
established titles is actually running a
massive Black Friday sale right now plus
if you use the code heavy spoilers you
get an additional 10 off go to
establishtitles.com heavy spoilers to
get your gifts now and help support the
channel thanks now dark repeatedly had
the triquetra popping up as a symbol
throughout it and 1899 has triangles
with lines running through them this
symbol actually has roots in Witchcraft
and its use as an icon to demonstrate in
Earth element we learned this triangle
belonging to the company that
refurbished the Kerberos but it's
something that constantly appears
throughout in episode 1 we see it on the
back of letters that the passengers
receive and all Sun earrings that
Clements wears sorry I need to make that
a bit more French Clemons now she also
has a hair clip with this in two and the
triangle appears on the signs used for
The Cabin numbers the triangles of
course used on the floor panel let's
discovered in episode 2 and immediately
after this there's triangles on the
cupboards this is a reach and a warning
you it's a reach but the priest year is
goatee it's a triangle anyway moving on
the carpet has the symbol on it too
which we see towards the end when the
bug is set free you also have triangles
appearing on the morse code message
which is brought across to the device a
triangle is also on the pendant that
Maura has at the end of episode 2 and
cut to episode 3 to see one on the back
of the geisha's dress the arrows on the
buttons are also of course triangles and
episode 5 gives us a good look at the
ships crew who all wear triangles on
their hats the boy also carries a
triangular pyramid device which later
appears in the Wasteland outside the
Asylum this is a very important thing
and the triangle with the line in it of
course refers to this in the end the
line represents a slate with the top
opening up and this is where Maura
places the key in order to escape so the
entire time they're basically saying
look the triangle there's a little thing
that flaps up which great bit of
foreshadowing and we basically have a
coup that forms on the ship after the
captain decides to tell the Prometheus
back instead of continuing to New York
if you're a fan of dark then you'll
likely recognize him as being a
character that I'll just call the
traveler in case you haven't seen it now
knowing what we know at the end
potentially he wants to turn the
Prometheus around because subconsciously
he wants to go back home got a lot of
Shutter Island Vibes from this due to
his family's death but beyond that maybe
he was responsible for it he might want
to return home to face up to his crimes
however their deaths might be a metaphor
for him leaving them on Earth he's of
course the captain of the kerbros but
beyond that he might be the captain of
the spaceship this might be a
manifestation of his regret him leaving
them back on Earth and basically that
explains why the Prometheus is littered
with reminders of them his family's
connection to the ship also mirrors
Mora's brother apparently being there
too now during the exploration of the
vessel they discover the young boy
Elliot and we also see Daniel climbs
aboard too mysterious deaths start to
happen and the more superstitious people
on board come to the conclusion that
Elliot is causing them ahead of this is
Ivan whose family also becomes pivotal
as we get into the storyline turns out
that a suncrester and her daughter Tove
got on the wrong side of a vicious
farmer who shot the former and sexually
assaulted the latter to have killed him
and now she's pregnant the younger
sister is killed early on and this
spares them on to take out the person
that they blame they also want the ship
to continue to New York and thus the two
sides are formed Daniel warps them out
of the ocean and messenger list is Bound
for the Prometheus with both Maura and
the captain's name on it weird things
begin to happen though with Elliot
coming back from being touched overboard
and a strange black wooden shape starts
forming in the hull secret Chambers
beneath the floors are also on Earth
which leads to a vast Wilderness with an
asylum lying at the center of it we
learn that this is extremely similar to
where Maura grew up and discover that a
father built it for her mother Maura
tells us that after she had her two
children she really started to forget
things and slowly dementia to cover her
father resented Maura and her brother
because of this and he built the asylum
in order to study the human brain he
wanted to find a way to repair it and we
learned that he also owns the company
that refurbished the two ships this is
an added mystery to him as he constantly
pops up throughout and we see that he
has TVs which definitely wouldn't have
been available in the 1800s Elliot
refuses to talk on the most part and
instead he writes things down like
they're watching us I hope so too mate
channels go got a million Subs but not a
million views per video really there's
actually also two things that are very
similar to a certain recent movie that's
just come out with people jumping
overboard and us also getting the words
sink ship anyway after Elliot goes into
the Wilderness and the passengers
fracture off we join Moore and Ike as
they head out to her fathers at the
center is the reveal that Daniel is
actually Maura's husband which was
teased early on by him carrying a photo
of her now after the captain goes to
attack him he transports him to a place
where we see several other versions of
the Prometheus at this point barely
anyone on the curb house is left and we
see a sea storm beginning to roll in
this is actually a shutdown of the ship
and the loop that's in it with the world
starting to collapse now the final two
episodes are where things really start
falling together Netflix actually sent
out the first six for review but they
held these ones back so that no secrets
got out also if you're enjoying the
video a bit of a segue would really
appreciate the thumbs up and make sure
you subscribe for breakdowns that are in
ship shape condition there anyway after
a romantic memory with Daniel Amora we
get a very important discussion about
what reality is Maura talks about how
one's brain very much created its own
reality and this of course links in with
the ship she says reality doesn't exist
if one's not there to experience it
unless a person's brain interprets the
world around them and creates a
construct in which they see the world
Plato's Cave is brought up twice in the
final episodes and in case you don't
know this is basically a thought
experiment that determines how we Define
what reality is it states that if a
group of people were tied up in a cave
together that they would assume the
Shadows on the wall and the sounds that
Echo around the cave are all that there
is they would be unaware that there is
anything outside of this and it would
become the norm that they'd end up
accepting this would be a false reality
but it would be what they Define to be
real due to the shadows and sounds being
all that they know in the show this ship
at the end is very much the cave without
determining what people think is
happening and really they're all bound
together experiencing the same thing and
thus believing that's the truth we see
at the end that each section on the
Prometheus is divided up into cabins and
it's even possible that each one of
these has its own simulation in world
now this room where they get it on is an
extremely important location as it's
also where more or later discovers that
she and Daniela Elliott's parents this
might be when he was conceived which
explains why it's such a powerful memory
for Daniel as she didn't have access to
this knowledge before because her mind
was confined to the reality that was
given to her which we see beneath the
floorboards this was her child at home
which is why her father was a central
figure that was also connected to it as
well this was the place that he
experimented on her mother but it's also
the place where she selfishly tried to
prolong Elliot's life I'm guessing that
time works differently in the simulation
and that keeping him there could mean
that he lives for decades from his point
of view it's sort of doing an Inception
with the subconscious being similar to
what cobbin Mao built with their dream
homes I'm still a bit confused over
whether Elliot is actually dead or not
but either way Mora did keep him
innocent at some point to keep him alive
potentially people's bodies age slower
under stasis and she forced him on this
trip across the cosmo so they could go
somewhere that he could be cured this is
similar to what we saw with Lucian who
was apparently traveling to America to
get life-saving surgery he might be
going across the Stars to have this
carried out and the end goal may be
someplace both he and Elliot can get
their treatment and Daniel did have
memories of Elliot because his reality
was much later in life when more and he
had had a child together we also learned
the passages beneath the passengers
rooms or leader their own past places
and defining moments in their lives
Daniel is locked in the main chamber
though he does eventually find a way out
Maura climbs back on board the ship and
we see the buck Awakening by Kate Chopin
published pronounced that wrong
definitely but it was published in 1899
and this was about turning attitudes
over feminism at the turn of the century
it was very much centered around the
condemnation of women which is of course
a reference to Mora and both her father
and brother's treatment of her how about
the Awakening also has a double meaning
about her very much much beginning to
wake up to what's going on you also get
a strong focus on her room number 10 11
which we also see is the number on the
treatment room in the Asylum I did look
about the ship at the end to see if it
was present there but unfortunately I
couldn't pick up on it so if you manage
to you've done a better job than me and
let me know in the comments I described
as a bad dream Maura goes through the
ship looking for Captain Ike crawling
through the tunnel she discovers a
recreation of his home whilst Daniel
winds up visiting several locations as
he climbs through the framework we have
what I believe is Angel and Ramirez
before we get to Olex Maura herself
winds up in Daniels and she starts to
see the truth Daniel returns to Maura's
memories and climbing through a grave he
comes across Elliot who gives him a
wedding ring he returns to Mora who
finally starts to accept the truth and
after she brings forth the key the pair
attempt to escape before or restarts we
discover that the loop lasts eight days
and that Daniel became aware of it and
passed through the ports during the
restart it's basically like when you
play the computer game a number of times
in a way aware of how to cheat through
the game whereas the NPCs inside aren't
Olek is taken out by a wave lucian's
seizures become too much for him an
angel is killed by Falling Rubble with
he and Ramiro telling the other the
truth that they love them the ship
starts to sink in Franz locks one of the
flood doors trapping himself in order to
save Tove I've been an anchored round
two and very few people are left at this
point those that died do so because they
can't let go of the past all the people
on the ship that they feel emotionally
invested in this is very much echoed
immora who refuses to let go of Elliot
who discovered that each character on
board the ship had a traumatic
experience in their past and that
they're reliving these painful memories
because they can't escape from them IV
the Prometheus as being a getaway for
them and rather than facing up of their
past they are running away from it
Kieran could potentially be obsessed
with studying the human mind and he
might be using these Journeys as a way
to turn those on board into his guinea
pigs if his father owned a company that
built these ships then he would likely
inherit that and now be running it his
sister and father would be the only ones
capable of taking away control from him
and this might be why they're locked up
inside of the simulation this also makes
me think of The Twilight Zone episode in
search of an exit this followed five
characters stuck in a construct trying
to figure out how to escape in the end
it's revealed that they're all dolls
dreaming of a reality similar to the
discussion of the doll's house that we
get in the episodes it's also somewhat
similar to The Evil Within which
basically followed someone trapped
inside a simulated nightmare the care
Bros is pulled into a cyclone in order
to start the next cycle and this
transports it to the ship graveyard
where the other ones were taken thus
breaking morale of the loop becomes
Paramount and her father tells her that
he just needs the key from here we go
into the finale which shows a key moment
of [ __ ] Elliot's time together it's
revealed that the bug is something he
found and he named Alfred and Mora tells
Elliot it would be wrong to keep it
trapped this is of course a nod to
what's going on in the show and there's
very much this idea of not keeping
people in cages now being transported to
the ship graveyard also seems to lock
them in two as most of the floor panels
are covered up however they managed to
get into Daniels whilst those on the
ship watches the virus takes over
Maura's father runs Elliot through
what's really going on and we see Maura
was the one that actually placed Us in
the simulation obsessed with the story
of Plato's Cave she decided to create
this simulated Loop that keeps him alive
but it also hides from her that she has
a child because of the painful memories
that would come with it she is very much
the key which fits in the pyramid and
tells her to wake up Daniel has other
plans though and he wants to wake Maura
up without giving the key to her father
he hacks the Mainframe and this also
allows the passengers on the ship to
step into the traumatic memories of the
characters which somewhat bleed into
each other yeah they finally said died
on the share but but they are corrupted
as we know in reality they are okay but
on the outside their minds may now be
broken because of kieran's experiments
aiki shut down on the Asylum by the man
inside who yeah got no idea what his
actual name is even even the subtitles
yeah they just call him crew member so
yeah if you know leave it below also
change the reality of this video so it
didn't make any mistakes that and I also
got his name and made it the best
breakdown ever that would really make my
day and Mora makes it back to her father
and her dad Alters it so we see the
extended opening of the series we
discover that she is the Creator and
that she builds upon her father's work
though we know that Kieran was involved
in this too it's also important to bear
in mind that Daniel is said to have
built simulations as well he wanted to
use them more for good and it stated
that they were all created as a way for
people to escape their own pain I
believe that Maura wanted to escape the
death of Elliot which is shown by the
fact his room is under a child's grave
the memories of him are very much locked
in here and I don't know if children
would be making such a big journey
through space however her father does
tell him he's the key to it and he
seemingly wakes up though not fully him
being the key could mean he's the person
who makes more realize the truth about
their son and this could snap her out of
it either way she's built this with him
inside so they could loop around with
each other forever her father takes the
key but it doesn't work because Daniel
changed the code and allowed the
corruption to take over we learned that
he switched the pyramid and also placed
the key in the wedding ring this deletes
the simulation and Mora wakes up back in
the wilderness now rather than
restarting it he's taken them back to
the first simulation they built Daniel
gets her to activate the new key and
she's State he'll always be there
however upon her coming to he isn't and
there is a number of reasons that this
could be now potentially Daniel is Left
Behind on earth and the character we
meet is more of a program he used to
wake Maura up if her brother ever takes
over he might also be dead that's that's
a theory we'll always go with him there
might be dead uh yeah and she could just
be imagining him using him as a
construct he might be on the ship as
well but either way Daniel tells her
that her brother is now running things
and that he's taken over the entire
operation and that takes us in a theory
time three time whole video is basically
a theory time because I don't know no
idea what's going on don't don't watch
any more of the video you wasted your
time don't
okay so I think that Maura probably made
this journey out with her brother and
she was hit with the painful memories of
what happened in her past so she decided
to hit up the old SIM and just chill out
her brother used this as an opportunity
to take over how about there's also the
potential that they both agreed to go
down for the long nap and he woke
himself up he then could have put Mora
in an endless Sim so she couldn't break
from it and then launched his coup
either way he is aware that she's woken
up and we close out the series zooming
into her eye this is important
iconography as we typically pulled out
the characters when we re-entered the
simulation I think the next season will
be about her reuniting with Daniel on
the ship if he is alive or if he's just
a program or whatever he is it seems
that he could be a prisoner as his
entire Mission here has been to break
her out of it however like I said he may
just be a Fail-Safe to get her out in
case her brother takes over Kieran
clearly has no issues with mentally
torturing people and taking him down is
definitely one of the main priorities at
this point the guy sounds like a bloody
nutcase and it really asks you what
would happen if someone insane was
running the Asylum I think it'd be even
Wilder if it's actually revealed that
this whole ship is its own simulation
and they were even further into the
bloody future that's a wild Theory time
for now and I'll stop talking crap all
the time on time if you look closely at
Maura here you might also notice there's
a lot of veins on her face guessing that
space travel just drains you and that's
why it's easier to stay in the
simulation I do think that next season
Maura will discover that her son is in
fact dead and she'll start to put
together all the pieces of why she ran
away in the first place maybe she
actually willingly gave herself over the
simulation and her brother could be
helping her because that message at the
end it does it could be interpreted as
being something nice with her being
labeled the creator also putting herself
in blocking herself off mentally there
might be another side of this story and
though Kieran is clearly torturing
people it could also be revealed that
Maura has had a hand in it too I'll
probably have another theory video
coming out soon as you can't really
trust anything in a show that said so
how heavily around simulation but those
are my initial thoughts on what's
happening at the end here now if you've
been following the channel for a couple
of years and you know that we absolutely
love dark picked it apart a number of
times and it's one of my favorite shows
of all time because of this I was really
anticipating this series and I'm happy
to say that I thoroughly enjoyed it
after when a show has three brilliant
entries it's expected that a series by
the same team should match up to that
instantly going in I thought this would
be difficult for 18.99 and that it would
be on the same level of dark season 1 if
not slightly below it however I actually
think it's better than that season and
the cast in central mystery are just as
enthralling as the later entries of that
series would end up coming to be a dark
was limited by the fact that a lot of
people in the west wouldn't give it a
chance because it was a foreign language
show in order to combat this I think
they've made it so the series has a wide
number of actors from all over the world
without being a multitude of languages
so everyone can be on board pun not
intended I'm glad that they did that
though as I think everyone should
definitely give this series a shot it's
super psychological and it will
constantly keep you on your toes as we
watch the mystery what's going on
playing out before us 1899 is massively
presented with there being a feeling of
an ease throughout the entire thing not
only do the languages make it so the
characters can't fully communicate with
others but the environment itself is
constantly shifting and confusing them
this is very much how the audience feel
too and throughout it there's a great
atmosphere to the entire thing that just
makes it unnerving shutting mostly the
darker dim circumstances you never
really know what's going on in the
characters minds or the show itself this
makes it gripping to watch and I was
constantly sad trying to figure out how
everything linked together the cast all
feel distinctive as well too and each
one has their own backstory and traits
that make them unique and special
sometimes in shows the side characters
can often get lost or whether it's the
costume designer acting I can pretty
much remember every single character
that appeared in the series they are all
fully three-dimensional people hiding
skeletons and that closet and you
understand what drives them and also
what their hopes are this is a testament
to how good the writing in the series is
or as the concepts of high-level shows
like this can often distract from the
people involved you do see performances
that make the characters so complex I
think 1899 balances both its characters
and concept really well and it's an easy
recommend from me those sons of a
[ __ ] are dark they've done it again
and 1899 is another highbrow shell
that's gonna suck you right in as you
try and figure out what's going on with
the characters scores are very very very
very solid 8 out of 10. and I'm excited
to see what these guys bring to us next
time obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the series so make sure you
comment below and let me know we are in
a competition right now and giving away
three copies of House of the Dragon
season 1 on the 15th of December and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the season if you pick the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now so that's you then message me
on Twitter at heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our Brighton of black
panther wakanda forever which will be
linked on screen right now lots of
things going on in the film and I'd
definitely love to see you over there
right after this by the way thanks for
sticking through the video I've been
Paul I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]